and it was also a cultural shift to
happening when young youth took over
rebellious well no but just you took I
mean the movies were not about kids up
to that point really and then they
discovered in the early 80s my God these
kids go to the movies five six seven
times grown-ups go once let's make
movies for kids and we were right there
at the right place at the right time you
know and so then John Hughes comes along
and says oh wait young kids emotions
should be taken seriously
um and you know because nobody's when
you're 17 18 you fall in love for the
first time you were the first person to
ever be in love right and so and that
first heartbreak is the first heartbreak
ever and is the magnitude of it and John
Hughes knew that and honored that and so
kids saw that one that's me
you know and that's why generation the
Next Generation those those women have
shown their daughters and their
daughters looking at that moving Pretty
in Pink and going the hairdos are funny
but that's me you know yeah and so
that's why they live on in that way and
to sort of you know for me to come to
represent that's beautiful thing but I
always kind of not always I never looked
at it like that like no but now I'll
here you go of course the Jew that's so
interesting it's like yeah you you
didn't realize the impact it had on you
guys it sounds so cool now and to
everybody on the outside looking in I
want to do the brat pack but I could I
could see how it was just sort of like
I'm more than that yeah or I'm
other than that yeah I am more than you
know that's
yeah and for someone like me I was very
much a you know a solitary personal
loner a bit so to be slumped in with all
these guys who I liked fine but I didn't
know them I don't think I ever went out
socially with any of them ever you know
really so you never you were on these
movies on these hugees I lived in New
York and so I would just whatever but
did you get close with anybody
yeah I mean I liked him but I mean no
but you never know any of them no
because I saw the article yesterday that
came out or the other day
um about Emilio Esteves you hadn't seen
him in 30 years yeah I hadn't seen any
of them I made a documentary recently
about this because I wrote a book a few
years ago about my time then my life
then and because I was like it was a
rock I never looked under and so I
decided to look under it and I'm like
that's how I came to the position that I
sort of was just talking about how I've
come to realize what a beautiful thing
it is and what I'm blessed in that way
really truly and then but I didn't feel
that way and so I thought that okay I
had a size that was a seismic event in
my life the brat pack what was it like
for everyone else because I know it was
for them too because we were in the same
boat we're members of a club we didn't
ask to join and we have we can just look
at each other and kind of go
hey dude and we just know and so I went
back and talked to everybody who Amelia
hadn't seen 30 years Rob I haven't seen
in 30 years to me you know any Ally she
hadn't seen any of them and to just get
their take on it and it was really
interesting